there's one area we should circle back
on learning about the company itself
it's extremely important to research the
company you're interviewing with before
your interview as we mentioned before
you'll likely get asked about why you
want to work for the company but you are
also likely to get asked about what you
know about the company's products
especially in the area you would be
working in near the end of the interview
you could also utilize the information
you've researched to help come up with
detailed questions for the interviewer
themselves in order to avoid asking
generic questions let's take a quick
look back at the job posting from before
one of the first things to know about
how the company describes itself is in
its commitment to community this would
indicate to me that I should check out
some of their community initiatives they
do the next paragraph discusses more
about their focus on transportation note
that this is broader than the most
common area they are known for in
ride-sharing know who they consider
themselves competitors with realizing
that they are about mobility and
transportation as a whole means there is
a wide range of companies they see as
competitors as opposed to what you might
expect this does not include in the job
description while this course was being
developed lifted recently acquired a
bike sharing company and had announced
plans around scooter sharing as well
that was fairly easy to gather from some
research of press releases news and blog
posts but it's important way to show
that you're knowledgeable about and care
about the company